we'll try and do our part to conserve
water here in our state but residents in
one neighborhood watching their water
flow right down the street yeah it's a
leak it's on Yamhill street right near
Paradise in Wigwam neighbors are
concerned they haven't been seeing
anybody trying to fix it 8 News now's
Brian will spoke to some homeowners and
got them some manner answers take a look
at this leak behind me well it may not
look like much it's been consistently
flowing for over a month now winding
through this subdivision and residents
say it has them frustrated
I can't believe it why are we wasting
this much water that's what Robert
Carnes is asking as he and Michaela
Rodriguez watch this water flow down
this street every day and I've been
trying to call him off and on for the
last
week and got no response out of them
they came out sometime in the last two
weeks and marked this but they still
haven't done anything about it I call
him for the water district they never
answered several neighbors tell me they
reached out to the Las Vegas Valley
Water District but most of their calls
went unanswered so I called the same
line
sorry we cannot connect or call at the
moment
please try again later
I then reached out to the public
relations Office three times on Tuesday
trying to get these folks help I love
that we're in the floor for one month
already
several blocks later this is where that
leak finally ends now this water will be
reclaimed most of it at least that
doesn't evaporate off but residents just
want this leak fixed before something
worse happens reporting near Silverado
Ranch Brian will 8 News Now
Brian's call did help a short time ago
the water district reached out to him
they will be making those repairs they
say tonight the delay was because they
say word wasn't passed on that they
cleared the area for those repairs we
will update you